rise & grind come on it's a new day full
of new opportunities new possibilities
let's crush it on this week's coffee
with Cannell we're gonna be talking
about pho po po po come on
fear of other people's opinions if you
ever want to succeed in business on
YouTube in life with marketing with
social media you've got to get over the
fear of other people's opinions and over
the next seven episodes of coffee with
Cannell we're gonna be going through the
seven steps in YouTube secrets of having
a successful YouTube channel now of
course this applies on social media
Instagram across the board and number
one the first C of the seven C's of
YouTube success is courage come on you
got a punch fear in the face punch
perfectionism in the face and press
record but one other thing that holds us
back is faux paux and so we're gonna
talk about it today plus in this show
coffee with Cannell we bring you on in
the second half to answer your questions
about life business entrepreneurship and
of course online video so hit the like
button if you're fired up whether you're
watching this live or on the replay in
just a bit I'm gonna give you a link so
you can join me for some Q&A but during
these coffee with Cannell episodes right
up front I deliver some quick value
around this week's topic and the first C
of YouTube success is courage and one of
the reasons that holds us back is fear
of what other people think would you be
so bold as to tell me in the comments
it's good to see a rich noah diane if
you have ever worried about other
people's opinions come on I know I have
this is probably one event has been one
of the biggest things that has held me
back I remember when I posted my first
video publicly I've been doing video
since 2003 I started at my local church
but when I posted my first video
publicly I was so nervous and I was I I
was not even being myself in fact I
actually have a little clip here because
I was afraid of what other people
thought I thought that if I let my
personality come out big if I share a
little bit of my humor if I was myself
man people will judge me and guess what
they will
but you got to get over the fear of
other people's opinions look at this
first video I wasn't being me I just
press record but I was not being me
check this out
alright so this is I guess the first
Shawn thinks blog and I'm gonna try to
vlog every single day mainly so I can
remember what I'm even doing and what's
going on because I just feel like I have
a lot that I'm thinking about and I
figured hey why not share it and if you
find something interesting that's
awesome now this is definitely as real
as it gets so I'm not gonna try to be
energetic or entertaining though maybe
sometimes I will but anyways
when I look back I have realized that's
ridiculous like I realized that I didn't
want to I was putting myself on YouTube
in 2010 and I was living in a small town
called Marysville Washington an hour
north of Seattle and I was generally
being reserved and I was nervous and
I'll be honest with you it's because I I
was afraid of what other people would
think I was battling with that in my
mind guess what
ten years later I steal still deal with
faux paux I just have to get over it I
just have to realize I got to post the
video anyways I got to post the podcast
anyways I got to share my voice anyways
and trust me oh I get some haters and I
get some comments but I've learned this
that haters are gonna be your elevator
so hey right up front before we get into
Q&A we're gonna give you I want to give
you a few tools to overcome the faux
paux come on we got a deal with with we
got to crush the fear of what other
people think
listen to what Aristotle said he said
this in 322 BC okay so 2,300 years ago
there's a no tik-tok yet come on there
was no there's no shaming there was no
online bullying yet come on 2,300 years
ago this is when Aristotle the Greek
philosopher he said this he said look
there's only one way to avoid criticism
do nothing say nothing and be nothing
Wow
like if you want to avoid
other people's opinions guess what no
posts no videos don't start a business
don't do a facebook marketing campaign
don't do a podcast don't share your
opinion don't share your voice don't
create a product go lock yourself in a
basement somewhere and dos don't do
nothing and guess what problem solved
but I know that if you watch our content
that you want to build your influence
with a video that you want to start a
business that you want to make a
difference look man if you're if you're
gonna start a church you're gonna get
criticized come on Jesus did if you're
gonna start a non-profit you're gonna
get criticized like the only way to
avoid criticism is to say nothing be
nothing do nothing and I've learned that
men everyone's gonna judge everything
you do doing come on parents other
people are gonna judge your parenting
style
come on other people are gonna judge you
in business I've learned this that when
you really step out of your comfort zone
you start to blow up your business a
little bit especially if you do some
digital marketing you got to be willing
for some people to have some backlash
they're gonna misunderstand you they're
gonna judge you they're gonna they might
even be right guess what their opinions
might be right but what difference does
it make you still got a beat you put
your voice in the world and so the
question is is it possible to overcome
the fear of other people's opinions it
is and I've got a couple tactics but
here's some questions to ask if to
determine if you are experiencing this
are you playing it safe are you afraid
to take risks are you afraid to put the
video on YouTube or listen what video
are you afraid of putting on YouTube
come on are you just playing it safe in
a certain category or topic but there's
the topic or something burning in your
heart and in your soul but you think if
I post that people are gonna judge me
people are gonna judge that topic are
you playing it safe are you afraid of
what's on the other side of the critique
what if I get a bunch of dislikes on a
video what if I get a few negative
comments on a video what's gonna happen
it might be good to play that situation
out because what is the worst that could
happen it could be it could be hard I'm
not even gonna minimize how personal
people's attacks against you can be but
it's good to play it out are you afraid
of what's on the other side of
critique post whether you're watching
this on Facebook or YouTube do you have
a fear of ridicule ridicule or rejection
how about this when you are challenged
do you surrender your view pout points
this is a good one because it's like how
confident am I in my views and am I
willing to just bend as soon as I'm
challenged or am i putting my real
beliefs my real confidence my real
message out into the world has a
negative comment criticized or paralyzed
you from moving forward in the past come
on you know how real this is for YouTube
Shawn I thought this was like tactics
and strategies for growing on YouTube
and building your influence it hits this
is like the number one issue
faux paux so a friend of ours benji and
i co-author of youtube secrets years ago
started putting out content real early
in the youtube game I mean like 2008 and
started really grow starting to really
get momentum and these videos really
started to help him grow his tech
business but he started to get a
backlash of criticism and what's crazy
is I learned this too as a tech YouTube
oh man everybody's got opinions and a
lot of times I make mistakes too they'll
be like you said it was an HDMI output
when really it's an input and it's three
point one not two point one all right
dude chill bro take a sip of some coffee
man you need to relax or maybe like some
tranquilizers cuz you got a chill I
remember I made a huge mistake I was
talking about these IPS monitors same
what monitors I'm using right now IPS
stands for in panel switching but on the
Box it said image perfecting screen and
I was like these have an image
perfecting screen you might not even
know what I'm talking about but like
people were like he's such an idiot he
said the wrong thing and they were right
I actually said the wrong thing but
listen if I was afraid of people's
opinions I would have never posted that
video and after a while I started
realizing that wait a minute I see you
in the comments bro but I've never seen
you at the bank come on somebody for
real man I put the video out there I
shared about it it got views is about
these asus monitors video was like for
350,000 views these monitors are
freaking awesome just because I said the
wrong thing about IPS which believe me I
learned my lesson but I wasn't gonna let
fear of other people's opinions hold me
back and you know a couple thousand
dollars later
in online income I was thinking that's
cool you got opinions in the comments
bro but I can't cash your opinions to
pay for my mortgage I got Sean Bradley
on the way I can't cash your opinions to
pay for some baby food and that carriage
carriage that stroller that I got to get
my son
I'm not saying be indifferent or be rude
or pompous but I'm saying all day long
people are gonna opinion opinions about
you what are you gonna do let it stop
you or you're just gonna put the content
content out anyways as I've gotten
criticism some justified some not
justified on YouTube I've just kept
posting new videos are you paralyzed by
the fear of being disliked you got to
get over the approval addiction man I
just want other people's approval if
you're looking for everybody else's
approval you're gonna be looking the
rest of your life - my people of faith
man you know proverbs says this fear of
man and intimidation is a trap that
holds you back being afraid of people is
a trap intimidation of others is a trap
and it'll hold you back but when you
place your confidence in the Lord you
will be seated in a high place come on
there's something about being just
confident in who you are who God made
you to be that he will woah of greatness
into your DNA but you're not perfect
that you're gonna make mistakes that
you're gonna say dumb stuff but guess
what every single troll in the comments
pointing out the dumb thing you said
they said dumb stuff - and they're
afraid to press record and actually post
a video all they got time is to think
about comment on what you're doing
meanwhile you're building your dream
you're building your vision you're
building an empire I got to keep going
we're gonna get to some questions in
just a second Popo we got a deal with
the faux paux so are you being held back
by any of those things do you hesitate
to not create content because of
worrying what other people think you got
to deal with this that's why the first
see and YouTube secrets is coffee is
courage because you got to just summon
the courage to get over the fear of
judgment to get over the fear of other
people's opinions to get the courage to
press record and post the video on
YouTube House have you posted your first
video on YouTube how many videos have
you posted let me know in the comments
and so here's a couple tactics first of
all a couple facts fact number one you
want to deal with this it's
that people will judge you like just go
into this knowing people will judge you
you want to start a business you want to
break the status quo you know a lot of
times when you start something that is
maybe bigger than your peers meaning
everybody you want a lot of times
everybody around you wants to keep you
at the same level when you start
striving for a bigger vision when you
start a new project when you start
saying you know what I want something
better for my future I want to be
tapping into more optimism I want to
build something great I want to stretch
myself people might start criticizing
that because a lot of times you stepping
out and stepping up shines a spotlight
on those around you for maybe the lack
of vision or the lack of confidence or
the lack of determination they have
don't ever let somebody who's given up
on their dreams try and talk you out of
yours it happens it happens a lot so
number one accept that people will judge
you realize that anybody who's ever done
anything great gets judged they do great
leaders in history have been judged
great actors the movie was amazing the
movie was terrible she was so beautiful
and a dress made her look so great that
dress made her look terrible she is her
boldness and her courage to share her
voice Oh her voice sounds annoying like
people gotta opinions all day long man
what do you do about it like you gotta
just get over the fact like anyone doing
anything is arrow top Aristotle taught
us is going to get judged and remember
that opinions are more about the person
giving them than they usually are even
about you like people project their lens
of life so they project and here's
another one you're worried about people
judging you you judge people all the
time oh can we get real and hit the like
button or tap the like button gently on
this coffee with Cannell I feel fired up
today
um you judge people all the time like I
think about it you know like I like to
think that my wife Sonya and I are not
judgmental people that we love people
but we have opinions about people behind
their back all the time can I be real
like so do you like especially I don't
know maybe it's in your own head but if
you're with
your partner you're dating your spouse
come on you're driving down the road and
you see something what do you do you go
what is she wearing
that's what is that like uh dude you got
opinions you turn on a Netflix show with
some freaking actors that have spent
their whole life protect perfecting
their craft working on their skills like
practicing their lines shooting their
you know their scenes that they put
millions of dollars into this Netflix
show and into this budget and you turn
it on laid-back eating some bonbons
bonbons like who eats but like eating
some Cheetos you're watching TV you're
sipping a beer like you're chilling out
and you just go that's her acting is not
that good you got opinions about
everybody you watch some youtuber and
you go oh I don't like her and like like
oh she comes across kind of over the top
why she over the top dude everyone's
judging everybody man this should be a
relief for you except that people are
gonna have opinions that's all it is
like whether it's judgement or not it's
just like people think you're too fat
they think you're too skinny they think
you're you're your voice is too high
it's too low
people got opinions about everything if
you let people's opinions hold your hold
you back you're never gonna create the
content build the business do the
podcast post the thing start the
campaign launch and step out of your
comfort zone and do something great you
just gotta accept the people judge
people and and and I think we judge
people too we have an opinion like you
somebody walk anyways people judge
people here's the second thing though
these are just the facts you got to
remember that people also might not be
judging you and you're actually
projecting on your your own insecurities
on those watching or those that are not
even watching so they either are judging
you or you're also just projecting your
insecurities remember the whole thing
it's like don't worry about what people
are thinking about you because they're
not even thinking about you cuz they got
enough problems of their own
like I just I just know that Sally I
mean she saw that Facebook post and
she's judging the fact that you know my
husband and I decided to have another
kid and even though and like and you're
making up a whole script and like
Sally's been on vacation like she
doesn't even know like like she just
might Sally might not be judging you so
either accept that the
our or remember that they also just
might not be and you're just projecting
and either way determine to move forward
regardless because you got to get
courage you got to punch fear in the
face and you got to post your video when
are you posting your next video and what
is the topic you've been afraid to maybe
talk about another level of courage to
share potentially a polarizing point of
view that you've been holding back on
let me know let me read you a couple
quotes I got three tips and then we're
bringing people on if I got Alina what's
up Alina we can share the link and get
some people in the back zone of stream
yard are you getting value out of this
let me know share this with somebody
who's been judging you lately
hey you need to watch this let somebody
share this with somebody I think I
hopefully don't have value okay listen
to this these are some important things
to think about when it comes to the faux
paux look when you do not seek or need
approval you are your most powerful
picture a day when you create the
content that you want to create without
fear of what other people think your
your most powerful when you get over the
need to be liked it might not be that it
goes away you still might think many
people are gonna judge this I'm gonna
share it anyways I'm gonna make a hard
decision I'm gonna do it anyways as a
leader I'm gonna make a change that I
know will rub about half my team the
wrong way but it's the right decision
I'm gonna do it anyways cuz it's the
right thing to do even though I'm gonna
be judged the day the day you stop
caring about what other people think is
the day your life begins yeah I got some
quotes for you Zig Ziglar don't be
distracted by criticism remember the
only taste of success some people are
gonna get is to take a bite out of you
come on Zig Ziglar and the only taste of
success some people are gonna get it is
taking a bite out of you they got so
much time how do people have time to
worry about what you're doing yeah I
know I don't got time to worry about
what other people are doing I've learned
that those like I think about my peers
in the industry of like entrepreneurship
social media YouTube like we have a
really good relationship at a pier level
and a lot of people will maybe send
criticism from outside but I think one
of the reasons too we're just not
worrying about what other people are
doing
I got too many things on my own plate
got a baby on the way went to the baby
store to do the registry they're there
for like three hours with the little gun
I didn't know there's 99 different
unique items snot suckers freaking you
don't just need the stroller you need
the you need the car seat but you need
different basis so you have a different
base in other cars and what's the safety
rating of it and then do you got the
creams and the ointments do you got the
stuff for the babies but in case baby
gets a rash what do you got you got the
right moist towelettes do you got all
the right thinks come on moms can I get
an amen in the comments like you know I
don't got time and and some people the
fact they even have time to worry about
what you're doing I think is a greater
statement about who they are than who
you are sometimes the only taste of
success people are gonna get is to take
a bite out of you what other people
think is none of your business I want
you to maybe rewatch this and listen to
this again when you're getting into your
mode of shooting a video or something
because if you're all tripped up on the
photo and you're worried about the fear
of other people's opinions think about
these things Coco Chanel said it this
way I don't care what you think about me
I don't think about you at all
I think that's healthy like if you're
worried about everybody watching you're
not creating your best content and your
voice is needed your message is needed
you got to post that video online you
got a press record okay dr. Seuss put it
this way
who you are be who you are and say what
you feel because those who mind don't
matter and those who matter don't mind
come on dr. Seuss be who you are say
what you feel because those who mind
don't matter and those who matter don't
mind the people that matter most aren't
gonna be judging you and Eleanor
Roosevelt said it this way no one can
make you feel inferior without your
consent it is your choice to worry about
the Foucault's fear of other people's
opinions they're gonna have them if you
worry about him and you feel inferior
you've given away your personal power
she said it's your choice to give it
away or not
three quick things and I don't know if
we shared the link out to let people
join on the the link okay I actually got
to give it to Alina that makes sense and
so I'm glad I'm looking at that now as
we land a plane to get ready for the QA
things you got to do I got a little
fired up let me know forget about you
and overcoming some judgment about what
people think number one how do you beat
the faux paux this is some stuff out of
YouTube secrets the seven C's of YouTube
success over the next coffee with
channels we're gonna be talking about
this of course it's out on Amazon
everywhere
number one get around people that build
your confidence you want to develop
courage one of the fastest ways to do it
is to get around people that are gonna
build your confidence if you have been
joined our YouTube influencer community
that's just a free Facebook group get to
Facebook and jump in the group like you
got to get around people that are doing
things that are like Aristotle they're
they're saying stuff they're doing stuff
they're being stuff and they're not
afraid of criticism and if they are
afraid of criticism we're dealing with
it together you got to be around people
making moves you got to be around people
that are making bold and confident moves
and by the way people are gonna lift you
up and not tear you down people that are
gonna encourage you and not you know
speak down to you people that are gonna
say yeah flourish like if your circle
and those that around you are jealous
they should be celebrating you you don't
want jealousy pulling you down any kind
of toxic environment or toxic vibes is
not gonna help you build your influence
on YouTube this is mission critical
y'all I know it's like fun we get to
make youtube videos and build businesses
and stuff but we like have our families
on the line here we're not playing games
on YouTube unless you're a gamer you're
like dude I'm a I'm playing games I'm
like playing a Minecraft on YouTube
there's the opportunity to pay your
bills change people's lives build
passive income and so why are you
hanging the route or surrounding
yourself a people that are tearing down
your exit plan your strategy your why
you got a day job you're working on your
dream job and you have people around you
criticizing your dream job and
criticizing the fact that after hours
you're chipping away on your YouTube
dream you're chipping away on your
online business you're chipping away on
your entrepreneurship project don't
put your pearls before swine for real
like your dreams your family your
community your vision your future to me
just this is one man's opinion by the
way this is just one man's opinion
is why would you sacrifice that and
allow those around you to tear that down
you got to change your standards you got
to raise your standards you can't talk
to me that way or we just won't hang out
I got I'm on mission man I got stuff to
do
and you just are angry and mean and
critical I got stuff to do
hey just be careful about your circle
get around people that build your coffin
it's number two get a clearer vision get
clear on your vision and values how
clear are you on your vision and values
one of the ways to get over a fear of
other people's opinions is to have a
mission that is more powerful than your
critics so men I get criticism and the
bigger your platform gets the more the
criticism increases and people will
misunderstand you they'll judge you oh I
make mistakes and people point them out
I also just say stuff that I believe and
some people don't like it when I have
done over times one of the reasons why
our business has blown up it's because
we've been willing to do Facebook ads
and Instagram ads and guess what that
makes people mad that makes people mad
because marketing pushes into their
newsfeed and whatnot we try to do it in
a way that's as good as possible but
here's the alternative fear of a lot of
people gonna think what happens think of
me is gonna keep you small so you either
blow your business up you either embrace
modern marketing you're either willing
to be misunderstood or you just say nah
you know what I'm gonna play it safe you
know what I wanna say anything I don't
want to do anything I don't want to be
anything I want to avoid the criticism
so as a choice I don't like the
criticism so I read the comments below
this guy is just a fraud
this guy is just and you're like - that
kind of hurts man do you don't know me
but I have to make a decision to push
past why my mission is bigger than the
kritis
coming my way so my mission fuels me
more than the worry of what people think
what people are saying and so you got to
get clear on your vision what are your
values like literally write them write
them down
what is your compelling vision in the
absence of a great vision pettiness
prevails but when you get to get vision
to get you your motivation gets you get
you something to fight for you go okay
I'm willing to press through challenges
okay what are your top values see when I
think about I value generosity I value
encouragement I value building people
not tearing people down
I value entrepreneurship I value family
I value speaking life not death I value
propelling others forward and I believe
in abundance not scarcity so I believe
that you winning doesn't mean I'm losing
I believe that there can be win a win
win win win win situation a lot of
judgment comes from insecurity that
thinks if you have something it means I
don't
and so my values are from an abundant
place and so a lot of people will
criticize that but I just think man I
don't even under I can't even actually
get into your mindset of being critical
and judgmental and tearing others down
because I just wants the other succeed
man I want to see others flourish and
prosper and just because your YouTube
channels growing doesn't mean mine won't
and there's a lot of people in the world
and like more people come in online
every day what are your values what is
your vision so how do you overcome faux
paux number one get around people that
build your confidence audit your circle
number two get clear on your vision and
your values write them down and get more
clear on knowing where you're coming
from because again when someone throws a
fiery dart of criticism your way if you
are on unstable ground not knowing what
you believe who you are you doubt
yourself
self-doubt then someone else's doubt
compounds it I know maybe they're right
no they're not right or they are you
know I mean you go yeah they are right
but I'm making a decision to go forward
they're criticizing my belief my my
decision in integrity they're
criticizing me standing for my values or
they're just criticizing or like they're
wrong like what they're saying it
pure troll troll pure poison I know who
I am I know my motives I know where I'm
coming from so it doesn't affect you
because you know who you are what's your
vision what are your values write those
down and number three take action as we
get ready to bring on some people with
coffee with can oil do you want to talk
about would you be willing to talk about
a little fear of other people's opinions
today have you been
have you been held back in stepping out
on YouTube today we're dropping the link
and you could click and then come on and
we'll bring you on the show the third
one hit like if you been gettin value is
take action take action the way to
overcome fear of other people's opinions
is to take action so post that video put
that podcast out finally write that blog
post or stand for that belief put that
Instagram caption out say what you
really think say what you really believe
what's the alternative not actually
lifting your voice and sharing your
voice because you're afraid of the
comments or get or you're gonna get or
you're afraid of what other people are
gonna say self-expression sharing your
god-given voice just as much right as
people have to share their opinion you
have the right to share yours as well
and that's at the end of the day all it
is we should be secure and who we are
and who God made us to be and we should
be willing to share our voice share our
opinion and put it out there in the
world hey if you're gonna come on as
much as possible try to make sure that
you got the good audio you got the good
internet connection you've got the good
vibes and we're gonna do some Q a couple
things to know about inside of our world
today let me know if you got value and
what was your biggest aha moment or take
away from overcoming the fear of
judgement in other people's opinions we
got to kill the faux paux and we got to
put that video out into the world that
was the first C of the seven C's of
YouTube success we'll talk about one of
these a week as we get into the Q&A
section and a couple things there is a
way to if you've been checking out think
media you you've heard about some of our
classes or our mentoring or coaching and
all that kind of stuff but you're on the
fence when it comes to those types of
things and you want to talk to somebody
you can get on the phone with you at
talk with think.com so at talk with
think.com you can sign up for a
discovery call and you book it on
calendly and then US residents non-us
residents and we jump on the phone with
you and you schedule that that's if it's
not a coaching call it's if you are
curious about our events you're curious
about our coaching programs you got a
business and you're wondering with what
you teach about YouTube work for my
business I've been watching a class or
something and I'm wondering about how I
can go to the next level and go further
faster talk with think calm talk with
think calm if you can do me a favor drop
a link to that over on type that out
because I'm going on multiple platforms
the software or using stream yard I know
a lot of people sometimes wonder about
that and and you can go to talk with
think comm will also drop this over on
YouTube as well and so if you want to
talk with think comm thanks for doing
that okay and then one other thing if
you want to take your YouTube channel to
the next level and you haven't seen my
class think master class comm I've got a
free training it's one deep training
from our video ranking academy program
but it's entirely free and at the end of
it we talk more about like our YouTube
coaching program but if you haven't
watched the free web class watch it
because it's totally free and you could
get value out of it start getting
results with it right now listen content
consumption is up across the board more
people are watching content we need to
master these tools and master you know
live streaming video and all those types
of things and so if you haven't seen our
master class it's over at talk with
think no it's over I think master class
calm all right love it love it love it
I'm looking in the back we have a couple
people ready to jump on um again I need
to see ya I hope you have good audio and
a good internet and we're gonna get
going I think some of its looking a
little sketchy so
try to get to like a good lighting good
area or whatever and man we've got
what's up my man how's it going watch
from Hugh might talkin to melty with
recovery netic LT yeah nice - nice to
meet you show on face to face here yeah
thanks so much for coming on the show
and what's going on what it what kind of
business do you have or YouTube channel
and how's this lockdown been affecting
you
I've actually capitalized on the
lockdown because as soon as AAA and NA
meetings and in-house treatment
facilities for drug addicts and
alcoholics went down they were searching
for support so I decided to go 73 days
ago live every single night and we've
been live every night since and so I
kind of capitalized on it for that
reason because we wanted support but we
started a non-profit to support reak
recovering addicts as well and we're
trying to grow this YouTube channel we
just barely started in January and it
kind of started taking off pretty good
in February that's amazing so you
started in January it starts taking off
in February
then the lockdown happens in Cove in 19
and I love and I just want to highlight
and and acknowledge you for taking
massive massive bold action I bet to
have the lives been had they been messy
I mean lives are like imperfect like you
just go live right you just committed to
it did you have to learn around the way
you ever have any technical difficulties
or anything um no actually I've been
studying this stuff for a little while
so I was kind of pre God kind of lined
everything up just perfectly and the
start you know stars lined whatever you
want to call it and we went live and
it's been pretty flawless technology
wise but the community that's growing
and it's like a legit loving caring
community where we've become a bridge to
a to a Facebook group where people
actually connect and you know you know
they get in each other's dm's and help
each other out and with they're coming
with suicide and relapse on the rise
they're really supportive and loving
that's just it's an amazing thing that
that's being built here
that's awesome well again
acknowledge you for taking massive
action I want to encourage everybody
wherever you're watching this live or on
the replay take massive action right now
and m.i.a take massive imperfect action
punch fear in the face that kind of goes
with the first see courage and just
start alive I'm not sure what its gonna
look like that's how this show started
as well coffee with candle we're like
okay I'm I travel schedule is clear
let's do something to try to connect
with the community so how can I help LT
what's a question you have so all my
videos so I have 10 uploads where I've
actually done the production side tried
to make fancy little videos ten of those
videos but ever since I've gone one hour
live so I have seventy three one-hour
videos and I try to do the SEO and it
seems like we grew really rapid and all
of a sudden now we're hanging I'm only
got 687 subscribers and all of a sudden
it's just like we've gone flat and I
almost feel like do I need to reef you
know now I'm getting confused past I
want to be here to help people to ose oh
do I need to reformat the way that I do
my 3/4 you know every 15 minutes of my
show and that kind of stuff you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah so the question is
how the show like how the shows are
performing on YouTube right because I
get a good audience I'm using stream
yard as well and I go Facebook and
YouTube yeah and we have a good solid 40
to 50 people divided by two because of
Facebook and YouTube and then our show
hits about a hundred to one hundred and
twelve views and then they just loop
they just drop off yeah yeah well okay
so here's a big thing in this I mean
there is something about the fact that
these longer shows this 3-hour one this
two-hour one they're not gonna do as
good maybe ever on on YouTube or
potentially even Facebook there there's
almost like two different purposes your
top viewed video is an eight-minute
video and I think that's potentially the
insight to think about is just that as
content creators and as business owners
and entrepreneurs we should have
different types of buckets of content
like I even think I don't expect coffee
with Cannell to do well it's about depth
it's about connecting with you it's
about hanging out in the commune
it's about talking a little bit about at
length about some you know fear of other
people's opinions and it's about showing
up every week but the videos that I am
if you will
treating its growth videos on thick
media or think marketing are highly
architected and this probably important
to say they're short like they're
probably gonna be under 10 minutes or
maybe they're gonna be 12 to 16 minutes
of highly optimized content not a lot of
long content is ever gonna do super well
on YouTube so to a point even like in
terms of like ranking or you know
performing and being discovered later
because a lot of people want quick
answers and so let me know if this is
adding value but I think there's
probably at least two distinct kind of
buckets to define for your strategy one
is like growth videos that would meet
new people and if you're gonna meet new
people you kind of want to meet them
it's kind of like a first date versus
like going on a six-day vacation with
someone you don't know it's like it's
like oh I'm just meeting you like you
see a girl you're like you know you want
to go to you know Ibiza for for a week
like I don't even know you bro like
let's just actually get coffee first but
after you know someone for a while it's
like you want to get married and now
you're going on vacation with them so
like the amount of time people spend
with you grows over time but you want to
get people a way to get to know you in a
way where we always say be brief be
bright be fun and be done and it kind of
makes me by the way your top viewed
video is this powerful video about meth
and alcohol addiction and you quitting
and it's eight minutes long and that
probably brings in awareness and then
people want to hang out with you in the
live show so could you create shorter
videos that could I hate to use the
analogy in terms we are talking about
humans and people matter of course but
but it's like fishing it's like bringing
in it's it's and so it seems kind of
crass from a marketing standpoint but
it's like bait it's like attracting I'm
not if I'm trying to even hang out with
somebody new online or meet somebody
online and I'm like okay my introduction
in them has got to be 90 minutes I ain't
got 90 minutes I'm trying to hang out
with like three minutes like oh that's
that clip was fire or that tip was fire
and then I might want to hang out longer
because now now I've been caught I've
been brought into the community I've
been brought into is that making sense
what
do you think about that it makes me
think about the strategy because I've
joined your your VR VR family yeah yeah
I've been listening to a ton of your
content and I was thinking maybe scale
back the live videos due to the hey
let's let's get married later to maybe
two to three nights a week and then
spend a good week making one quality you
know even from five to ten minute video
exactly what you're saying that's
exactly what I would do and that's the
power of a YouTube video that you know I
realize on alive even right now like if
I spend an hour and a half you know
going live on coffee with channel cool
but the replay value does have a lack of
optimization to it yeah whereas if I
spend multiple days making something
half short and twice strong as the
wu-tang says come on GZA or if i if i
make x you know if I invest my hours and
editing I think about heather Tauruses
video and this is a great example and I
want this maybe inspire you as we
transition so she did a video that we
talked about right and she's the host of
the think marketing podcast called
homeschool versus public school and
everybody watching and I think about
that she did this video when she was
dealing with fear of other people's
opinions afraid to get on camera but she
did it anyways and she punched fear in
the face the video has a hundred and
four thousand views so this would be a
life-changing video for your YouTube
channel but she shot it it took her
about two hours it's only seven minutes
long it took her about two hours to
shoot it trying to get it right trying
to hit all her points she planned her
points then it took her about seven or
eight hours to edit and then she put it
out according to the video ranking
academy process right with all the
optimization and titling and tagging and
the whole thing she followed the
seminars right and the thing is though
it still gets views every single hour
like right now it's getting a view an
hour that's twenty-four views a day and
it continues to grow her YouTube channel
but a lot a lot more energy than just an
hour long or a two hour long live which
lacks replay value this has been
replayed and viewed for the last four
years and there's also risk with that
because when you put in this much energy
to a video it may not act
we perform great for you but all you
really need is one breaking out to
breaking out three breaking out and then
you start growing your channel like
Heather's experiencing on autopilot and
then by the way she does live streams
rqa
and it's just two different things that
making sense is absolutely my man well
hey LT I appreciate you thanks so much
for coming on the show and love what
you're doing to to help people man it's
inspiring
thank you very much huh all right take
care see ya yeah yeah yeah coffee with
Cannell the show where we answer your
questions about YouTube social media
business
we've got mini on the show is that how I
say your name come on Amy welcome to the
show and we're you streaming from what's
your business YouTube channel and what
is that again oh Pennsylvania and what
is it you do what's your YouTube channel
and how's this lockdown been affecting
you well my question comes in my
question is how important or how it
straight should we be when it comes to
niching down because um I do have a
passion about I mean it's helping others
okay so I lost 125 pounds in about two
years
naturally just diet and exercise right
and I'm trying to help people to do the
same thing whoever needs that but I also
want to help others in other ways like
lately my last three videos have been
about how to grow your channel in
YouTube which is also kind of
self-improvement if you think about it
like the financial part but I don't know
if that's going way too out of my soul
or my niche okay and you have 40 videos
out is this your channel um let's see
yes and then if you notice the first mmm
20 maybe they were actually in a Spanish
and I was getting no traction
I got like 60 followers in like three
months and then in the last 20 they
I switch to English and I got like 219
subscribers okay well a couple things so
I will talk about this at a couple
layers first thing I want to encourage
you with it's just something to think
about okay this is interesting is is I
want to just address the fact that she
said I was getting no traction and I
quote you right no traction this is not
this is not no traction your top video
back when you were doing Spanish was 381
views that is not no traction like that
is no traction no right right so I mean
we got it so we got to say that so then
one of the things to also think about is
even 40 views in and this is this is
this probably affects all of us as
creators is it's hard to be patient and
it's hard to stick with things until the
breakthrough I I think about somebody
who's inspired me early on
his name's Gary Vaynerchuk a lot of
people know him in social media he did a
show called Wine Library TV and that
that's kind of what he got famous for in
social media and he did a 5 day a week
wine show where he talked about because
he his dad owned the liquor store that
you know they called Wine Library
eventually and he said for two years
five days a week two years 104 weeks for
two years five episodes a week every
single day nobody watched the show and
it was this idea of no traction but it
hadn't broke through yet but he stuck
with it and it may not just be you I
think there's people in our community
that need to hear that I totally get we
should be identifying where the results
are and where the growth is but when
you're four month ago video as 381 views
like that's amazing and I know that
you're seeing as subscribers and whatnot
but I think you may have judged it's
fine if you're pivoting the English I
think you might have judged it a little
too soon though because I see so many
videos with views in Spanish what do you
think you are there but then I was not
seeing like the people kind of sticking
out in meditation also was kind of low I
think I was in the 17
eighteen percent fish kind of thing so
that's why I did switch to English and I
started seeing the at least that number
go up like yeah the subscribers okay so
that's fair so if if you want to switch
to English I would hope that if that's
like a bigger long-term strategy if it
has increased the metrics a little bit
that's well that's good and I want to
encourage you again if anybody watching
wants to check out a book or you do it's
called the dip by Seth Godin
and it's the question of like when to
quit and when to keep going because
there is a point when you do want to
pivot you just don't want to the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing over and over expecting different
results
and so the dip is let's see what the
subtitle is here a little book that
teaches you when to quit and when to
stick that's the ultimate question so if
anybody you know it's got that exact
question it when should I quit and quit
could mean pivot just change and do
something different but when should I
stick it out there's something about
about sticking with something until you
get the breakthrough think media is ten
years old the first five years it really
didn't take off now my jaw wasn't
consistent either but now let's go to
the next question
niching down i ask it again well how is
tricked should we should I be with
niching down like if I because again my
passion is to help out people I'm a
mental health therapist so it's like
it's that's it might it's in my blood so
I know I can help people with like the
weight loss like kind of saying what I
did in a healthy way in an emotional way
uh but also I could help people when it
comes to like growing their own channels
and like for example if you see my last
video the second to last is how to get
free music like I'm non-copyright so I
know that was gonna help my own the
people who are subscribed to me who also
have channels I knew that was gonna help
them out yeah yeah so I mean at the end
of the day did you happen to be a part
of our youtube influence challenge I did
see I have to watch
most of the days but I will think I saw
like three or four of the videos
afterwards so we don't really have a ton
of time to go into it right now but this
is kind of what I want you to be
thinking about and we talked about this
on the challenge and maybe this will be
one of the coffee with Cannell or a full
video we do out here publicly but um you
know like whatever you pick I would want
it to be at the intersection of your
passion proficiency and where there can
also be profitability provided you want
this to maybe retire you or be something
you do full-time I think that you know I
think helping other people with YouTube
tips and whatnot you do have to ask
yourself at some level what results
you've got on YouTube this is my opinion
I didn't want to start teaching
YouTube and still until I had built
multiple five figures and then even six
figures in ranking videos and doing
affiliate marketing and then I started
to teach a system called video ranking
Academy once I had gotten results I got
results for clients so I like to think
about when I think about proficiency I
think about where are your results and
my about fell out of my chair when you
said by the way congratulations and it's
very inspiring you know you lost 125
pounds and healthily like that's some
serious results so that's an agent
cruising see fitness and helping people
in that regard I think it's very
powerful and it could be very profitable
as well and I would say I think you're
passionate about it and I just wonder if
you haven't stuck with these things long
enough when I look at your most popular
videos and we honestly don't have enough
data yet but even this Jim shark I mean
that video is great as far as views this
other Hall I think of other gym clothes
is great how you lost the weight you
know I think there's just something
about being disciplined and saying focus
now to the point of your niche so I just
wonder the the YouTube tips at this
point don't stick out to me like that's
that's not the direction I would go I
would go into what I see as your
personal power I do think that at this
stage though for you and everybody
watching I think you should give
yourself some room to experiment like I
think you can
over optimize at the start and you can
niche down too far too far so I think I
like the fact that it's kind of used
your personal brand channel by the way I
mean even what I see you've got this
awesome cartoon of you
you know like work that's amazing you've
got the new videos I think I think the
mindset like even when I think
proficiency like you're a mental health
professional so you're already a so like
you are able to help people on the
internet with their mental health people
need that more than ever before
people need home workouts right now more
than ever before and they need to get in
shape and they need to get off the couch
and they don't know how to do it so they
need to get their mindset right they
need to get their health right they need
if they want to feel good about
themselves and I want to find outfits
I'm sure they want to find supplements
they want to find things that will be
flattering like the Opera it seems so
clear to me and maybe that's the
serendipity of us talking here but
that's what I would lean into I think I
wouldn't feel too worried about at this
stage even you talking about like buying
a Tesla I think there's something about
maybe giving yourself a few buckets on
the channel to say okay there's two
videos a week and one of those videos is
almost gonna be like a workout or a tips
video about mindset one of the other
ones is going to be more about like a
practical thing about about weight loss
or whatever and then maybe you even give
yourself the ability to do like a
personality based because I do I talk so
much about clarity and niche down and
whatever that sometimes I think we do
forget or I can think I can insinuate
that you can't experiment with we bought
a Tesla here's our life here's what
we're going through or here's like a
vlog or something because at this stage
in the process your goal is to post as
many videos as possible look at what's
performing well and which topics are
performing well and then double down on
what's working if there's ever a time to
niche down to be clear it's later almost
went once you've identified what some of
your best topics are and let me just
like bring this home on think media I'm
crystal clear now but back when I
started at first I was like okay this is
going to be media tips and so it was
kinda like video
PC kind of some random media tips then I
started interviewing like a DJ
interviewed a DJ then I was doing some
like church media stuff then by the way
Tim Schmoyer from video creators nine
years ago we were hanging out that's a
classic and then you got you know other
music creators and then some like Church
social media we had Gary Vaynerchuk -
nine years ago we went up and saw him in
Bellingham Washington there's another we
had you know just a bunch of random
stuff and so I wasn't even really
talking about the stuff I talk about now
as far as you know tips for shooting
with idea Solara but it's still all over
the place I guess this is my point I was
on my clarity journey this wasn't really
what was working I was learning a lot
then look at this video tips and video
gear that we use for our videos so you
have like 900 views a thousand views
4000 views but then this guy hits 12,000
views where I'm like hey we're on a
shoot here's all the stuff I'm using and
I actually do a video where I go here's
my tripod here's my camera and I get
disproportionately more views when I
start talking about all the gear I'm
using which again was like it seems
obvious now here's this you know packs
here's how we set up for shoots but it
wasn't super obvious to me then and so
then what we doubled down on was tips
and tools for creators my point is your
YouTube journey and everybody watching
might be something like this where you
need to have a clear direction in my
opinion and you're going after some sort
of a cohesive brand I mean look at this
best video editing laptop 236,000 views
I started seeing best camera for YouTube
225,000 views so wisdom would then be to
be like okay double down on what's
working I started to shift the content
and then think media really started to
blow up and grow and I started to
basically turn it into what it is today
so is that helpful I think there's
something about knowing you've got a few
kind of buckets of content like what are
the topics that your channels really
going to be known for but it doesn't
have to be too narrow you experiment a
little bit but then you double down on
what's working
once video start to blow up and who
would have thought maybe it's for
example like maybe it is like work
out close it probably you know like who
knows and you're like I didn't think
that would be what it is but if all of a
sudden now people like man she's the
best I'm talking about all the Jim shark
stuff and now Jim shark wants to sponsor
you well then maybe that's the direction
you want to double down on you know what
I mean like you just do kind of a lot of
things within that category and then as
give it enough time patience and then
identify the winners and DoubleDown is
that helpful yes some of my um
Oh my doubts yes I just need to be more
patient let's say that that's funny cuz
I'm a therapist I say that all the time
to my clients yeah and I love that you
look you've got 40 videos which is
awesome but like you don't want to be
overly judgmental of your first 50 to
100 videos how many how much schooling
or education have you gone through in
getting to become a mental therapist
mental well I did my bachelor's and
master's and then I mean the licensing
journey I already took my state
licensing exam so I just need my hours
so to be a licensed counselor yeah so
like probably how many years about 7
with the with the internship and
practicum so would you look at somebody
who you're you're like this pro you've
been doing this for seven years you've
been going to all this school and how
many like patients have you seen or
people have you coached or helped so I
would say 150 175 I don't know if you
see the trap I'm setting for you here
the point is okay seven years working on
your craft interning for years helping
people a hundred and seventy-five people
you've helped if a young aspiring mental
therapist you know came to you and just
said I'm so discouraged I don't really
have total clarity and you said well
what's going on they go well I'm a
freshman in college and I've seen zero
patience I'm not
sure if I have what it takes what would
you tell them to be patient that it will
come to them yes and you got to keep
putting the time and so I just want to
encourage you I hope that inspires
everybody else to to think okay you got
to keep posting videos and you got to
post some bad videos to get your good
videos and it's okay to experiment and
post you probably look back on on
patient 1 through 10 and you think shoot
I hope I didn't mess him up like I hope
I mean like I learned some things on
that one like those that like I just
pray they turn out okay because those
like we we gotta be willing to you know
start messy start imperfect and so
anyways thank you so for being open and
sharing your journey I think that your
future is really bright on YouTube
you've got you know some great momentum
you got a cool vibe you've got you've
had you have incredible experience and
people need your 7 plus years of
experience your 4 years of seeing
patients they need the results you've
gotten in your health you'll be able to
help a lot of people but be patient and
keep posting thank you so much thank you
thanks so much for coming on the show
appreciate you hey can anybody relate to
needing to maybe be patient a little bit
and that we wish we had it happening
sooner let me know hit the like button
if you've been getting value out of this
episode of coffee with Cannell today's
episode is brought to you by youtube
secrets we're talking about the seven
C's of YouTube success over the next
seven weeks on coffee with channel the
first ones courage you got a press
record punch fear in the face but then
you got to be patient and keep posting
on the journey and so I'm excited for
our next guest here Janka how's it going
man what's going on where are you
watching from what's your YouTube
channel and how's this pandemic been
affecting you Hey so yeah gingka and I'm
watching from TJ one of Mexico and the
Bad Nexus has been pretty good I
two eminent I'm an engineer sighs to
kind of work in and out so one day I'm
at the office and the other day I'm
working from home oh yes it's been good
my channel is links why I am kzz and
yeah how can I help man so I am a travel
advocate so like my channel really is
trying to be based on travel anything
travel so travel related I just want to
be known as like a travel guy so Travel
Tips travel experiences travel anything
but it travels and you know right now
with the whole Cove it it's been a
little interesting since you can't
really travel no doubt
I posted as much videos as I want to and
I just feel like I think I'm definitely
seeing some growth but struggling with
how to get more people to actually stick
to the channel yeah yeah I mean that's a
great question that's like one of those
things right where it's like you know it
you can't control it is what it is if
this your industry or travel itself has
been decimated I mean it really has like
I just saw that currently if you look at
the worth of zoom the live stream
software Hertz is the top seven Airlines
that zoom a live streaming software's
market cap is 48 billion and Southwest
Delta United International Airlines
Group the top 7 Airlines is 46 billion
zoom a software is worth more right now
than the top 7 Airlines that just tells
us how incredibly affected travel of
course flights have been I think what we
need of course remember is like this too
shall pass so part of it it's just being
like dang I mean this was out of my
control and I think that potentially it
then comes to the next stage that you
have to make a decision and think
through you have
couple options one is to just literally
be patient and like wait it out and or
to pivot and say okay you know it's kind
of like as soon as people Xerox which
was the copy company that was making
Xerox copy machines or he'd go back like
when the typewriter was displaced by the
computer people were no longer buying
typewriters if you decided to stay in
the typewriter business it was a losing
decision not the trap cuz travel will
bounce back assuredly we don't know when
and so are you gonna be patient and
write it out are you going to pivot to
something different pivot your plan go
different direction and those are kind
of the two choices or both I think we
all need to be patient right now because
we don't really know what's gonna happen
and even be patient with growth on
YouTube that's the next factor your
growth on YouTube I would encourage you
you you said should you travel during
the corona virus outbreak it got good
views so in the meantime you were still
adapting to that and I've four you got
300 I mean more views than your
subscribers so for where you're at on
YouTube you haven't posted that many
videos you're still early in your
journey so you also could be a little
bit overly judgmental in terms of even
what is happening right now does that
make sense I mean yeah you're early in
the game still so that's like the third
X Factor Kovan 19 happens
are you pivoting trying to come up with
new content and you also just need to be
patient in general with starting your
new channel so I don't know if that's
encouraged like if that's helpful but
that's kind of what I see more than
anything is are you thinking about
pivoting are you thinking about waiting
it out like what's what's your thought I
think I'm definitely gonna wait it out
because travel is always gonna be part
of my world actually because eventually
it would be too long run would be a long
time you to monetize to release for sure
and like I said you know just be a light
and just be able to encourage people to
travel more if that means what jet
troubles are because I realize a lot of
people actually do not know how to
travel and I wanted to be that guy to be
able to help them out with that I love
it I would leave me is I my echoing I
mean yeah let me mute this here yo yo
check check check check so uh so I would
lean into that as we land the plane you
you've made the decision I'm gonna keep
doing travel I would think that it
already feels like it's softening so I I
would think about what video topics can
I talk about or where could people go or
how could people go safe maybe your next
travel like to even say not should you
travel now but how to travel so jump on
the plane show the mask show like the
hand cleaner show how to do it whatever
in Mexico maybe show where you could go
what you could do there if people can go
now shine a spotlight people are gonna
get restless they already are they're
gonna want to go places serving that I
do think there's also then something
about the pivot plan of thinking about
you know trying to get creative like how
can like maybe tips on traveling like
five tips for traveling in your own
neighborhood allow your own area like
how to get out and see things that you
never really saw before so we all need
it and we all need an outlet right now
especially where we're really locked
down
we need creativity we need different
ideas and then what I would encourage
you is yeah keep doing like topic
research keyword research like looking
for smart video ideas things you could
jump on you know brands to work with or
whatever because you're always one video
away from changing your whole life and
business with YouTube but also you're
super early I mean I think what we have
like a total of of about less than forty
videos or something out there so just
like the last combo we were having just
keep posting and Steve Jobs right the
late Steve Jobs founder of Apple said
that business is a game of attrition
meaning most people just give up if you
want to if you want to win and
this just keep standing if you can be
standing three years from now six years
from now eight years from now 13 years
from now your competitors will have
given up gotten distracted gotten tired
got fatigued business is a game of
attrition so if you don't quit you win
and again people it's actually I say
this with a level of empathy because
it's super sad right now for some they
are unfortunately crushed by this
recession crushed by the lockdown it was
out of their control the big question is
if they could have just righted it out
the lockdown eventually softened and
some it's literally heartbreaking
because it was not their fault you know
what I mean like certain restaurants and
whatnot they just did not have enough
cash or enough capital enough staying
power to ride out the storm to get
through to the Sun on the other side so
I want to encourage you with that keep
persevering to keep posting and to find
a way what's nice this was beautiful
about this YouTube thing is we can build
these as side hustles you can keep
wearing your engineering job you know
it's if the breakout moment for you is
in six months or literally if it's in
six years people will come and go
they'll get bored they'll get tired that
is like human nature that's why Steve
Jobs were saying he's like look dude no
majority of people ninety nine out of a
hundred are gonna get weary and give up
so if we can just keep standing be smart
with our money be smart with our pace
be smart with our strategy continue to
pivot videos and whatnot then if you
don't quit you win the finale
good advice thank you very much my man
hey I appreciate you thanks so much for
coming on coffee with Cannell and thanks
for being a part of our community thank
you very much
all right man yank appreciate you bro
thanks for coming on and you can check
out links on YouTube man I gotta travel
where are you traveling next who here is
getting a little bit Restless restless
from staying home from being locked down
we're gonna bring on we have time for
one more we're already over time but I'm
gonna bring on Deepak because I've seen
him on here multiple times and so I'm
fired up that he's been a part of coffee
with Cannell we also got
hit the like button if you've been
getting where do you want to travel next
you've been Restless are you excited to
travel Jael is gonna travel downstairs
to eat dinner soon I like that when do
you travel in Vegas that's awesome let's
let's kick it we're gonna bring back
Vegas influencers it's not quite set up
right right now but Vegas influencers
calm we do a monthly meetup we haven't
been doing it now it's a Q&A show live
on on this channel think marketing
depending on where you're watching this
because we've been locked down but
eventually we'll be hanging out again in
person and and so anyways appreciate you
let's do the next one deepak am I saying
I'm wrong yes absolutely
gonna get me hey thank you so much for
coming on the show
I've seen you a couple weeks in the back
studio and so I wanted to make sure to
get you on here and I want to appreciate
everybody else too that you know you
jumped in the waiting room and whatever
we do this show every single week and so
I have a hunch that someday you'll be
able to get on here if you just keep
showing up hey tell me about what your
business is how this lockdowns been
affecting you and where you're streaming
from I think I'm just I'm streaming from
Houston at the moment and logged on has
given me thing to think to me I am I
couldn't if I would have been they know
logged on I wouldn't have got think so I
think this is the biggest benefit that I
got in this logged on and yes finding
thing Wow hey appreciate that
yeah because otherwise I would have been
going to office every day and I hardly
go on my Facebook and so I think this is
the life-changing moment for me and I'll
tell you why I'm a basically a
professional speaker and a corporate
trainer and I recently moved from India
to us for my personal reasons and I have
totally changed my profession here
because I have to pick up a job in u.s.
so I was I think the paid job in
insurance but that is not my area for
the last many years have been corporate
trainer so in u.s. are now I'm trying
my service professional speakers so I'm
part of National Speakers Association
here and trying to set up myself and I
was struggling to find what kind of
niche I should pick up because I've been
training in many areas team-building
leadership and all the stuff but when I
came to us and a few days back if you
remember you talked about Toastmasters
and and I won the Toastmaster
championship here in Houston district
last year so so I basically after
listening to you and Ally attending this
YouTube influencer challenge I realized
this is my area public speaking and
communication because communication I
used to really teach in my training
programs and then public speaking is my
passion which I've been following for
last nine years I've been competing and
this year last year I won so so that's
why I found my niche because I was going
after leadership I started a YouTube
channel my channel name is Deepak Sharma
speaks so I started YouTube channel only
because because I was converting my book
which I wrote last year of stories into
stories however repurposing my content
so I was just putting one story every
Sundays and their stories but as soon as
I got to know about thing I got a lot of
new ideas and thought about it and I
realized that it is important for me now
to look at a very different perspective
and make it a communication mastery
channel so that I can so immediately I
put my speech couple of weeks back we're
in and also I started putting my I did a
training program on impromptu speaking
which also got some views better views
so I realized speaking is the area
that's amazing it's cool to hear that
story and Congrats on winning
Toastmasters and and I'm super grateful
that just being connected to our
community has helped you know you get
some clarity clarity is power what's a
question I can help with what what's
your biggest question right now so I
think I have two major questions one is
I I came to the US so my channel shows
that it is based out of us
okay but my I because of my spending
last 40
in India I have a lot of following in
India so when I put in my videos out
here nope I get because especially I am
recorded of my first video yesterday we
get to do my niche which I am going to
post very soon which is on why are you
afraid of public speaking so I'm that I
have done in Hindi which is in your
language so I want to expose this to the
audience there it will automatically go
or is there something else I have to do
on the channel so the question of what
is the question what language you should
lean into as far as the videos being in
Hindi or English no the question is not
that
I will be basically using both the
language but at this point of time
because in India the major challenge in
public speaking is people who are
speaking Hindi so that's why I posted a
video for them now if I post this video
will I will people will be able to see
that video in India or it will only be
populated in the US they'll be able to
see it but I do want to caution you of
trying to avoid uploading different
languages on one YouTube channel okay
because here's the principle you never
want to upload a video that your
subscribers did not subscribe for so the
question is using a business term of it
being a market like what language does
your market speak like if I wanna if I
want to reach Orange County moms you
know they probably speak English but
even more what language do they speak
what words do they use what language do
they use what topics are they searching
for what branding what marketing will
resonate with them now conversely
if you want to if you would say the
majority of the people I want to reach
that's your market are in India and this
is the language that they speak then
actually the majority of your content
not even the majority your content
should be reverse engineered for the
markets you want to reach I'm not a big
proponent of starting multiple YouTube
channels but when it comes to
potentially having multiple languages I
do think separating it out onto
different channels is important but I
just like to maintain a point in India
English and Hindi both are like we used
to very openly for example English is a
work
language and Hindi is the national
language and they're using they're used
in the same sentences by people yeah
yeah so we you call it English got it so
so that would be a good exception
because that's how your market speaks
yeah
so in that case and answer your question
you should be fine there's even a point
to we had somebody come on I've maybe
was coffee with Kanna last week check
this out
and they did fitness and they were
curious about reaching Asian American
males and I noticed these titles it's
written in English and then forgive me I
do not know what language is yeah yeah
yeah and so so so the answer though is
that is that even when I think about
what keywords everywhere is over here
it's showing tags in two different
languages so you
does it get convoluted they even have
tags in two different languages over
here they got a little bit of English
and then a little bit of again Korean or
Chinese or or whatever maybe somebody
could tell me in the comments so I would
say lean into that I'd say that number
one yes your content can be viewed
internationally provided especially that
you don't have any copyrights or any
limitations and countries or if the
country limits it but you should not
have a problem with that
number two you're gonna want to reverse
engineer your your if English is the
stronger language or maybe what your
whole audience will understand maybe
that's the full title or maybe there is
a little bit of both does that make
sense
you essentially I wouldn't package your
content to reach your ideal market so I
was trying to do in this particular
video I was trying to put thumbnail in
Hindi and title in English because the
people normally even in Hindi speaking
people with search in India title in
English yeah and I just gotta tell you
to experiment I you could follow this
like you could try actually English in
the title
and Hindi in the title he has only
English in the title put some videos out
there and test an experiment and see
what happens I mean that's that's what I
would say in regards to that question
but more than anything is to always be
thinking about kind of your market first
what is your market typing in search
what language are they typing it in
search what are they looking for in
terms of what thumbnail would stand out
to them this is what all of us should be
doing and often most of our audience
puppies speaks English but again when
you even think about more nuanced than
that what words do they use we call that
kitchen table talk versus classroom talk
or corporate talk if we want to reach a
certain person we might be saying a
fancy thing I for example I think media
Heather tourists the host of the fig
marketing podcast I can feel I think my
back it's in connection I think I'll be
back she says Heather tourists searches
Wow look at the pit stains that's a
whole nother level of uh
so Heather tourist says read background
versus how to get bouquet or boquete in
video you know bouquet i bouquets an
industry term or depth of field is an
industry term versus you know how to get
a blurry background is the way she would
word it and so everybody watching think
about how do you reach your target
audience what language do they use and
speak that language
Deepak can you hear me are we as it were
yeah yeah yeah problem I have one
another question quick question now I
have started thinking about this public
speaking so when I'm talking about
animation I realized that when people
speak then only they can communicate so
first they have to speak and then they
communicate if they don't know how to
speak they cannot communicate so I am
I'm looking at a picture and I look at
public speaking and communication both
as part of my dish is it okay or shall I
go more deep into it you're completely
on track public speaking is an aspect of
communication so I mean it's it's
thinking about
the multi dimensions of what your target
audience to the people you want to help
need and I think sometimes it's it's
seeing how many opportunities there are
in terms of video ideas or content that
could help and remembering that every
YouTube video is a pathway to get to
know you and you want to answer the
questions people are asking so that you
can answer the questions that are not
asking so here's what I mean the video
that really might attract your audience
might be what should I wear when public
speaking what colors should I wear if I
have a presentation see someone finds
you and maybe maybe because not everyone
sits Ana's like how do I become a better
communicator but they might think how
can I be confident so you could talk
about like how to how to communicate on
a zoom call because in general if you're
getting business professionals or
professionals how do I communicate when
live-streaming or how do I just be
confident on a zoom call that could
attract the right person to you so that
you can answer the question they didn't
know to ask so if I'm thinking about
communication and what people need to
learn to be a public speaker man it's
like maybe how to be funny how to start
a public you know small topics answering
like different topics how to be how to
tell jokes how to start a public talk
how to you know be persuasive when I'm
using zoom and and so like it could be a
lot of different things and so sometimes
in our niches around our channels it's
hard to see the forest through the trees
like there's maybe a lot of different
topics might have been video were you
thinking about doing a video on what to
wear when public speaking yeah also I
have a I've got 80 topics like all
you're talking about but it's humor but
it's storytelling whether it's opening
closing you know how to stage everything
I have that I listed on my list great so
and that's the dream then it's to just
do one of those topics see which one's
resonate double down and then throw in
your videos some questions as well and
maybe at the end of it say I and hey I
would love to know what is your
biggest challenge when it comes to
getting the confidence to speak or to
get on you know and then that'll also
continue to fill your pipeline with
ideas but I don't know if I answer you
that's you're completely on the right
track absolutely cool and videos a week
is fine it's not overloaded or it is
fine at this point of time I'm kinda do
that two videos a week yeah yeah I think
that's an awesome schedule yep like
that's that's a great schedule always
being willing to experiment but if you
can keep the quality like pretty high
you're delivering value in a way more
uploads if the quality is high is better
than less because it's more chances you
never know which video like it could be
a video you didn't expect again it might
be like like a quick little how to tell
a story in three steps and you didn't
think that was gonna be the most popular
video and it is that's the beauty of
YouTube and anybody watching let me know
in the comments if you've been doing
this long enough you go back in your
library and you're like oh man I didn't
realize my most liked my top three
videos it's just because you posted a
lot of videos you want to always make
them as smart as possible sometimes the
one you put your most heart into you
think this one's gonna be big will fall
flat and some that you think it's just
kind of kind of the average you didn't
expect it to do amazing will do really
well so two a week slow and steady wins
I'm super pumped we're connected and
thank you for your kind words about how
valuable think has been to to you and I
love what you're doing my videos yeah
you see my comments I'd be looking okay
for what I the professional speaking
niche I figured thumbnails look they
look solid in terms of they're they're
clear they're accurate like but they're
not my favorite I think the the design
level of your thumbnails could go up a
level again your thumbnails don't have
to be quote unquote like stereotypical
youtubers like using anything that's
off-brand for you sometimes as maybe
professionals you know we think like
what they look like to me though is they
look like like old-school kind of
PowerPoint thumbnails yeah this is
PowerPoint I made it oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
would consider and if if we have a some
of our favorite stuff is at think media
tools calm and where we talk about a lot
of different video editing tools and a
lot of different like where we get
royalty-free music and one of the people
that we partner with is called monster
thumbnails and not that you have to do
something like this but you know eight
thumbnails a month which is what you be
doing is is 250 bucks and there's other
solutions you could of course design
these yourself I don't know if money's
tight but there is something about
thumbnails are super super popular and
I'm trying to think you know if you
could get pictures in somebody's hands
or even with the the pictures you
already have there's something about a
professional design is a huge bridge of
credibility and and sometimes it's
potentially handing it off to somebody
else let me give you one other thought
if you use PowerPoint consider using
something like canva okay um and on cam
vidcom watch this it's pretty crazy you
can go you eventually get like a paid
account but if you go to like thumbnails
you know this isn't really your brand
but like you could go into something
like this
drop your picture where this eye is and
talk about like tell hell the perfect
story and like bang like thumbnail done
move elements around delete I mean oh
yeah sorry I'm over here so so I just
pulled this up canva calm and I don't
know if I don't know if I could drag and
drop in here can I did I do to work yeah
so I mean let's say can I send this to
the back this is in the wrong side so
this is you know against the
photographer this is this is quickly
just you know throwing something
together
so again canva.com things like PicMonkey
as well okay but you just go here and
and and it's like a few bucks a month
and so knowing that there's like quick
tools like this I would let even this a
little more Pro doesn't have that bad
power point vibe so again this is cour
canva.com if is gonna be blue on blue
but let's throw Heather in here real
quick and and so this there is something
about either taking a dedicated day and
we've got some videos that are on thick
media that talk about how to take photos
with your smartphone and whatnot they'd
be actually probably pretty easy to
change this blue less yeah let's go like
you know this pretty girl leave that's
kind of cool and you'd be like oh tell
your story and and then it's like you
know with Heather I mean this this
thumbnail just took you know seconds and
obviously yeah like and and it's it's
clean its bold obviously the photography
is strong and we have you know that new
video just so piece by piece we always
say right get one percent better with
every epilogue yeah and so just like
learning these things either with your
smartphone there's a couple things that
Omar just put a video out about how we
do our backgrounds and so this is like
creating a studio inside of you know
throwing up some construction paper
basically and that's where we take some
clean photos which is really nice you
know so I would check out that video and
then I think the other one is there's
Instagram thumbnails Omar give some tips
about quick thumbnails with just your
phone and one of our topmost click
thumbnails used just a stock photo it's
this adobe premiere one and it was and
you can make it an Instagram in a IG TV
or not IG TV but Instagram stories so
he's he just says like a picture using
his phone of his daughter Ruby types
that that's what that's what it's you
know free software this was a stock
photo of a laptop from unsplash.com and
and then using the text tool we just
typed it in the in there and and anyways
so those are a couple free tutorials
like would go got asked I would level up
your thumbnails
I want to encourage you with is that I
would I don't ever want to get stuck I
wouldn't want you to get stuck in not
post videos I think it's about posting
and getting one percent better posting
and not being like shoot I'm not gonna
post for a couple weeks until I get my
thumbnails right now like make them a
little bit better keep posting use canva
calm keep posting higher monster
thumbnails keep whatever it is and just
each week get a little bit better as
used grow as your YouTube channel grows
thank you so much my man thanks so much
for coming on thank you so much coffee
with channel the number one show Verizon
and grindin with Sean Connell like it's
the only show with Sean kid okay so hit
the like button if you got if you've
been get value out of this episode um
let me know how do you make thumbnails
did you see how powerful canva was look
at that that quick that that came out
just boom smashing it out if you want to
check out more tools you can check out
our tool page we've got a couple of
videos some of our marketing tools and
all kinds of stuff and so that's there
to help you every week we come to you
with this show and as a couple
announcements if you haven't checked out
our YouTube masterclass over the next
seven coffee with candles we're gonna be
talking about the seven C's of YouTube
success today was courage we got to get
over the fear of other people's opinions
man we had a press record and post our
videos watch the replay if you missed
the beginning I hope that was valuable
we got a lot of good feedback and I will
be going back and reading your comments
and following up with you thanks for
being here
what is your aha moment and what do you
need to do next I want to encourage you
I see people posting about what kind of
thumbnail Barbies using canva different
people are using canva a lot of people
use canva coding with JT tons of people
using canva Dericks and photoshop
next-level bro and so what do you need
to do next though do you need to work on
your confidence and actually get the
courage to press record do you need to
shoot your next video do you need to
make some thumbnails we're all about
taking action he
at the think media community and so I
hope you think different take massive
action punch fear in the face of press
record thank you for everybody that's
always in the hanging out and and that
didn't make it on the show today
just like deepak will do this every week
and so if you see me coming on whether
on facebook or think marketing we'd love
to have you on the show will drop the
link at some point and then you can jump
on and we look forward to connecting
with you soon
recovering addict LT i appreciate you
coming on the show hit that like button
or press it gently
however with whatever intensity you
would like to hit the like button share
this was somebody that needs to deal
with the faux paux in their life because
it's a big deal and it holds us back in
sharing our voice starting businesses
launching that project writing that book
writing that blog post doing stepping
outside of our parents expectation of us
stepping outside of what are the
constraints maybe our friends or family
have wanted to keep us in at some point
come on you got to follow that god-given
vision that he's put in your hearts and
that calling that he's woven to your DNA
randall we don't really have a same time
yet we want to work towards that but um
we hopefully will be figuring that out
you know more but most of the time it's
kind of a rotation sometimes it's in the
morning sometimes in the evening felicia
typed out her next step i need to make
thumbnails and make some videos just
press record
hey you typed it if it's not written
it's not real so everyone come on let's
post our action items let's post what we
need to need to do next
sandy says family is the worst love you
sandy thanks for being here
and connie patience and experimenting is
the biggest takeaway come on let's be
patient it was nice having inca and
minnie on a craig you're welcome thank
you for being here your message matters
yes Carla really appreciates you thanks
for being here Donald grateful for you
Joshua said is it okay to do a video
about a question that points towards
your channel of course absolutely once
you think about stock video embedded in
your videos I think stock video takes
your video up this video is kind of
boring because I'm just sitting on here
with
Dane's just sweat now in my 100 degree
Las Vegas weather and that's
embarrassing I mean that's unmissable
that's a screenshot okay don't post that
don't screenshot don't rewind the video
so thanks so much for being here
Alexandre Glen appreciates you coffee
with kennel the weekly show where we
talk about business live social media
and online video and man someone caught
that proverb how'd you find that verse
did you look it up the fear of man is a
trap
hmm oh that was even different though I
got problems 2925 for you the fear of
man and intimidation is a trap that
holds you back but when you place your
confidence in the Lord you'll be seated
in a high place come on we're getting
over that fear of other people's
opinions and we're punching fear in the
face Felicia says but she's still rock
even with sweaty pits that's right man
you gotta just press record whether my
mom once bought me she goes you're gonna
be public speaking I'd like a talk
coming up she bought me these pit liners
so they'd absorb the words or absorb the
most moisture so I wouldn't be
embarrassed on stage but now I'm on a
digital stage in front of you right now
sweating out my pits like crazy got to
start messy friends I hope that's an
inspiration if you feel you got a press
record poop your pants scared
sweaty pits scared nervous weren't about
people's opinions press record anyways
and yeah it's all good Thank You Barbie
hey I hit the like button thanks for
hanging out I'll see you in the next
episode new videos all week on think
media new videos dropping a video
influencers soon if you haven't checked
out the master class think master class
calm and if you want to get on the phone
talk with think calm links in the
description down below and in the
meantime keep crushing it keep smashing
it I appreciate you and I will see you
in the next one peace